israel's bombardment of the gaza strip
has continued for a seventh consecutive
day with air raids
dozens of palestinians are dead and
several residential buildings have been
flattened
181 palestinians have been killed since
the offensive began
well rescue crews are searching through
what remains of this building now
earlier there were hopes that
two brothers who had called from inside
that rubble
would be found alive they did manage to
get them out of there but sadly they
died shortly after arriving
at hospital they were among 33 people
who were killed in that blast 21 of whom
were from the same family now doctors
have told us that roads leading to
hospitals have been bombed
and medical services are being inundated
well arab leaders met earlier on sunday
condemning israel for what they called
flagrant violations of palestinian
rights
and the u.n security council will hold
an emergency meeting
in around an hour's time well we've got
a team of correspondents covering this
story for you
nida ibrahim is in ramallah in the
occupied west bank
harry fawcett is at the mount of olives
in occupied east jerusalem
sami abu salam is in gaza as is yumna
al-syads we'll go to her first she joins
us from outside the
al-shifa hospital
as i've just been outlining the death
toll continuing to rise
in gaza what more can you tell us this
are
just 15 minutes ago three girls were
taken out dead
from the rubble from abu dhabi family in
the street so we have 30 36
sorry three more 36 more uh
children that have been added to the uh
the death toll of the children that were
taken out of the uh rubble
uh also targeting of a multiple of homes
uh
here and there across the gaza strip in
in the southern area
in the central area uh which brings up
the total death toll
to 188 now uh
according to the ministry of health the
last uh statics
and uh we have a warning call that uh
there is a a azure building which is
just in the neighborhood and just close
to a shifter
complex where i am uh broadcasting from
that is going to be there is a warning
that this uh building is also going to
be
targeted so we're in a state of uh um
cautiousness where we're trying to be
cautious as much as possible because
it's very close
uh to the hospital which means that uh
the hospital might also be uh um
directly or might also be um for sure
uh affected by the targeting and uh the
missiles that would
uh target the building um so given that
we we saw you looking up
uh skywards as we were introducing you
both yourself
and samuel just a quick safety check are
you okay
can you hear any planes or missiles
incoming
at the moment
yeah yes there was just like us there
were the sounds of
of aircrafts and and drones around us
and
uh honestly because of this warning uh
call that we got about azure building
we're all in a state of consciousness
were all um
like uh anticipating that anything would
actually happen now
also uh rockets were launched so they
were just
above us and uh the the the sounds
whether by the aircrafts the drones or
the rockets
uh they make huge sounds that are
actually very
frightening and traumatizing to the
people here in the hospital
yuma you are outside the hospital just
give us a sense of what the situation is
like
in the hospital itself uh because with
all the
the escalating violence the buildings
the residential buildings that have been
brought down
uh safe to assume they're being
inundated
how is the hospital coping right now
well because of the overcrowdness that
is in the hospital
any uh middle or mediate
injuries or light injuries are quickly
sent
out of the hospital or sent home where
they can
uh be uh whether like by just
uh bandaging their their wounds or uh
cuts or anything like that and and just
sending them out
because there is any very very little
space left in the hospital and the
wounded
out of the rubble are still until this
moment coming by
in numbers whether deaf people or
wounded from the rebels and even from
the targeting that keeps on happening
every now and then the medical crews are
extremely
exhausted and sent out to different and
multiple areas
of the gaza strip uh everywhere
we get a warning call saying that this
building has got a warning call
that it's going to be targeted we find
that
there has to be medical crews and civil
defense crews
in that place in case of any uh
um civilians uh being under any rubble
or getting killed out of the targeting
and this is what is so much exhausting
to the medical crews and
the hospitals now the amount of people
coming
in and out of the hospital is just too
much
and this is what we spoke about earlier
that
the health system is almost collapsing
very shortly due to these ongoing
aggressions
that are still going on until now okay
you can hear the raids
now we can indeed hear the raids now i
want to make sure that you can get to a
place of safety there
yumna al just a reminder to our audience
as well
it is assuming we're assuming
we're assuming that the shifter hospital
is the safest place
unless something else changes and like
the previous
war it gets uh targeted as well well
let's hope that the schiffer hospital
continues to remain a safe place for now
uh
yumna outside we'll let you get to
safety just a reminder to our audience
is watching it is actually a war crime
to target a medical facility
let's uh stay in gaza we can cross note
to sami abu salem
he's a palestinian journalist and a
resident of gaza uh
sammy can you hear us are you okay where
you
are
yeah right now a little bit yes actually
we have just
seen the iron bomb is bombing and
we have heard lots of explosions we have
no details yet
it is just two minutes before and right
now at this moment the rescue teams are
evacuating and inspecting durability
evacuating
uh toys of children
from bedroom i have just been there and
i inspected
around i have seen lots of toys and
books and colors
and things relevant to to their kids
and i have here the neighbor says and
the rickshaw teams
are discussing about a bedroom of
children right there
and one of them told me there are five
expected to be five kids
under the rubble not confirmed why not
confirmed why
it is just expected maybe five kids or
more because logically we have to ask
the rest of the family how many guys in
under the rubble but the rest of the
family have been killed
so no details and maybe the kids are
dead
or not we don't know actually and
another picture of of gaza right now is
uh
the funerals people have buried the dead
people actually
here we are in the street it is one of
the main streets of gaza in this
street you are seeing now but those are
in the risky teams are working but it is
just
one location there are two other
locations
so in this street to other location two
three
locations uh uh are busy
and the risk team are working working to
remove the rubble and
locking and inspecting for their bodies
they are they are they are escaping or
in a trace with the time
they are in a dilemma why in a dilemma
they have to work
hard and very hard to to seize the time
if there is a live people but in the in
the meantime they have to be careful and
slowly
to keep the the people are alive so it
is very complicated that it
and it is very obvious that they
that the tools they are using is not
enough and
you can see primitive except this
bulldozer okay
uh sami abu salam there live
from aloha street in gaza
do stay safe thank you for bringing us
the very latest from the ground
we appreciate it uh that's the view from
inside
gaza we're going to keep a close eye on
those pictures as viewers will have
heard
explosions going off in the background
as our correspondents were reporting
well foreign ministers from the islamic
world held a meeting to discuss the
escalating
conflict in his opening statement to the
organization of islamic corporations
saudi arabia's foreign minister
condemned what he called
flagrant violations of palestinian
rights
and says palestine's foreign minister
pushed the international community
to put an end to israel's military
operations
all the free people of the world all the
people who believe in human rights and
justice
should reject this the palestinians are
facing a cowards occupation that kills
children
and terrorizes families this occupation
must be faced
it must be attacked we must put an end
to this occupation
we need to know what should be done
against the israeli aggression
well that's across now to ramallah in
the occupied west bank nira ibrahim
ibrahim is there for us nida
what do you think people in ramallah
will think of that statement
from the palestinian foreign minister
hala to give you a better idea of how
palestinians are perceiving the oic
meeting and also the expected meeting of
the u.n security council today
it is going to be the first open meeting
to give you more of an
idea we are inviting a palestinian
activist and we're joined here
by rena nazal who is a
palestinian-canadian activist
what are you guys expecting from these
meetings
well to be honest with you i don't think
that many palestinians
even know about this meeting and i'm
certain that no families are sitting
around their tvs waiting to see what
happens
all the crimes that have happened in
palestine over the last 70 years have
happened
under the era of the un they've happened
under the noses of the international
community
and i mean one has to ask what the point
is of a un
if it is only condemning and there is no
action to follow up
of course we want to see the un name
what's happening
by its name we want to see them talk
about apartheid and settler colonialism
about the genocide that's happening in
in parts of brazil
but i don't think we're very hopeful and
we've seen activists like you in the
past few days and we've been discussing
with them how they're viewing the
situation and they say that they are
disappointed frustrated with their
leadership
why do you think or if you at all think
that this time
the situation on the ground is different
than any other time
well i do think that this is one of the
first times in my life that i've seen
um in my adult life that i've seen every
part of the palestinian interior
and the exterior so many parts of the
international world
of the people not the states per se
actually
rising up in popular protest i think
that
we don't have much of a leadership to
follow here
i think most of our true leaders have
been put in prison or assassinated by
israel
and the political leadership that we
have here especially in the west bank
um has this abhorrent policy of security
coordination with israel
and i can tell you from you know from my
time on the ground that
um often we have to pass through a row
of is of palestinian authority riot
police before we can even reach our
protests with israel
and with a reality like that it's very
difficult to follow any kind of
leadership
and people have to take things into
their own hands rena i've been talking
to many people on the ground who are
some are optimistic by the attention
they're getting from the international
community
others are telling telling me that we
don't
we're not seeking anything from them and
i wanted to know how you're viewing that
in light of the
online campaign that is going on do you
think that's changing do you think
that's helping the cause
i do believe in the power of the
international communities people
i understand why so many youth so many
people have very little faith in states
and in
international actors like the un um but
i do think that
that that the people have power that
they have the power to support boycott
divestment and sanctions to push their
countries to sanction and i think that
they're raising their voices and we're
seeing this at unprecedented levels and
i hope it keeps going
thank you so much rana nazal she is a
palestinian-canadian
activist and we've been hearing from
many palestinian activists
that the discourse is changing on social
media that they are
trying to counter the censorship by
certain platforms
and they say that they want to keep this
going and show
more people in the world what's going on
in palestine that palestinians
are still living under the israeli
occupation
okay ibrahim they're live from ramallah
thank you nida